Vsauce Kevin here when Sammy the bull
gravano ratted on the mafia he wasn't
just saving his own skin he was engaging
in a high-stakes Game Theory exercise
because we all know that snitches get
stitches snitching is such a severe
social transgression that Judas Iscariot
has been paying for snitching on Jesus
to the Romans for nearly 2 000 years and
the 30 pieces of silver Judas received
for his betrayal is still The Benchmark
for an informants dishonorable
compensation even little kids have a
sense that snitching is disgraceful
conduct they ostracize the kids who
tattle or squeal
in southern Italy the code of conduct
known as omerta governed the mafia's
refusal to cooperate with authorities
against others within the organization
it was a Blood Oath and a pentito
someone who broke America was a rat you
take that off you never betrayed you
never talk you never say anything no
matter who violates you so are Julian
Assange and Edward Snowden heroic
whistleblowers who risked everything to
lay bare the truth or are they just
weasels stool pigeons or traitors it
depends who you ask but I think that
what seems like an issue of virtue and
self-interest is a lot more complex it's
a mix of human behavior and Game Theory
a combination of morals and math now we
actually play the game is so perverse
that we make it nearly impossible to
actually get to the truth
what's a stool pigeon an Antiquated
method for catching pigeons was to tie
one pigeon to a stool as it flapped its
wings hopelessly trying to escape that
attracted other pigeons to its location
where they could be captured easily so
calling a pigeon a rat with wings works
on a couple different levels the most
pure example of snitching and its
consequences is exposed in the
prisoner's dilemma you probably already
know how it works so I'll keep it brief
two men are arrested and they're
separated if neither snitches on the
other one police can still convict each
of them on a lesser charge with a
two-year sentence if one turns on the
other that testimony will allow a
conviction on a greater charge with a
10-year sentence and the snitch will go
free if both betray each other it's five
years each the payoff Matrix shows all
the possible outcomes of both A and B
snitching or not snitching and it
immediately raises questions about the
best strategy if your a should you stay
silent and hope B stays silent two two
years does it make more sense to betray
your friend and hope you go free if he
maintains silence even if it means
risking five years if the other guy
talks too if you snitch your possible
outcomes are 5 years or zero betrayal
means you will avoid a 10-year sentence
no matter what remaining loyal and not
talking gives you possible outcomes of
10 years and two years so what's loyalty
worth to you
it's irrational to put stock in loyalty
and the dominant strategy for both
players is to betray one another that's
the big game theory takeaway from the
prisoner's dilemma it's such a seminal
concept that its offshoots and
implications on decision Theory are
referenced over 62 000 times on Google
Scholar and the most comprehensive
analysis of all things prisoners dilemma
Stanford's Encyclopedia of philosophy is
over thirty thousand words in spite of
nearly 75 years of scholarship we've
obfuscated and flat out ignored the
aspect that dictates how this game
affects real lives in real life
The House Always Wins
in the prisoner's dilemma players are
incentivized to betray the worst case
scenario for a player is he honors the
code and his friend betrays him the best
case is he betrays his friend stays
loyal and he avoids prison time but even
in that freedom scenario he's branded a
snitch for life he'll face consequences
in the community for ratting out the
other guy even winning is losing but
there is no outcome where the police
lose they can only win it's just a
question of how much the FBI itself says
that informants have played Major roles
in the investigation and prosecution of
a wide variety of federal crimes since
the Inception of the bureau in 1908 and
even with clear published guidelines
about how informant programs work the
whole thing is a murky soup of threats
and payoffs and whether it's the FBI or
NYPD or Soviet KGB system of secreting
sotrunic it's always worked pretty much
the same way the cops need information
to prosecute criminals if they don't get
it through investigation they need to
get it through testimony sometimes
Witnesses are totally comfortable
telling what they know but most of the
time they're not because of the snitches
gets stitches repercussion and that's
when the game theory changes
in 2021 researchers discovered 19 Bone
Fish Hooks and six grooved stones on the
Jordan River in Israel they turned out
to be up to 15 000 year old fishing
tackle Hooks and sinkers haven't changed
that much since ancient times but how we
fish has fishing Clash lets anyone with
a smartphone or tablet travel the world
to engage in one of Humanity's oldest
sport and survival activities you can
compete against other Anglers upgrade
your rods and Tackle increase skills and
level up and all the while experiencing
real legendary fishing locations like
the lost world it's a fishing simulator
an outdoor fishing app and a PVP game
click the link in the description or use
the QR code to download the game and use
my gift code vsauce2 to get an awesome
20 value reward for free you'll get a
unique Avatar a mythical lure card 50
luck power ups and 30 weight power ups
to help you catch the largest fish
thanks to fishy Clash for supporting
vsauce2 and for helping me make the
videos I I want to make and good luck to
you on the water the one running the
game has two options threats and
incentives or both and the prisoner's
dilemma both players are offered
potential but not guaranteed immunity if
they give up the other guy co-defendants
and people arrested for other stuff are
offered everything from lighter charges
and sentences to full amnesty while
incarcerated informants can get simple
prison perks or full release paid
informants basically have a job and a
paycheck informants have to decide how
they want to play to avoid punishment or
balance their payoffs with the potential
consequences of those payoffs while the
game Masters just sit around and wait to
see how much they've won not a bad deal
maybe that's fair and the prisoner's
dilemma we know that both players are
criminals that's why the cops are 100
confident they can convict them on that
lesser two-year charge there's no
wrongfully charged man in the dilemma
and there's no guy trying to improve his
already Grim circumstances or looking
for a handful of cash but rewarding
snitches is such a twisted game to play
it almost got innocent people executed
for killing a man who wasn't even dead
in 1819 Jesse and Stephen Bourne were
convicted and sentenced to death in
Vermont for killing their brother-in-law
Russell Colvin there wasn't a ton of
evidence but Jesse born's cellmate Silas
Merrill said that Jesse confessed to him
in detail Merrill testified against the
brothers and was rewarded with his own
freedom from a forgery conviction but
just before Jesse and Steven were to be
hanged Colvin was found alive in New
Jersey he wasn't even dead let alone
murdered by the born Brothers it was a
rare win for justice and the cops who
always benefit even they kind of won
since they were spared from the wrong of
putting innocent men to death yes a
forger went free
Merrill's dishonesty reveals one of the
obvious problems with informant culture
an incentive to lie you already have an
inherent sense of the problems with
snitching but let's codify it when it
comes to criminal justice three things
matter what's known when it's known and
who knows it truth is not necessarily
part of that equation to start
informants are suspect because they're
usually implicated in anti-social
Behavior already so they're kinda
difficult to trust why wouldn't they
just make things up to hurt the people
they hate and protect their own and
don't all the benefits feel a little
like a reward for criminals but the
problems with the snitching game are
only the beginning sometimes informants
are forced to play a game within that
game witness intimidation happens when
criminals use their own system of
threats and payoffs to influence witness
testimony if a witness is forced to play
a game where the house always wins and
you'll face consequences for their
testimony then you can't win either so
your only option is to wreck the whole
game by silencing them if you've ever
watched any mob movie you've seen how
the mafia's omerta code is enforced but
what makes for great entertainment has
ruined real lives like Anthony Brown's
nearly half
half of death row wrongful convictions
have been tied to unreliable informants
Anthony Brown was sentenced to death in
Florida in 1983 for murder but the
actual killer testified against him in
exchange for his own lenience and it was
the same for Randall Adams he was
convicted of killing a police officer in
1977 while the informant who was the
real killer received immunity from the
prosecution in exchange for his
testimony neat trick want to go down a
rat rabbit hole Google Randy steidel in
Randy's case a cop sacrificed his own
job to expose the truth about the snitch
system that wrongfully convicted him of
murder Randy spent 17 years in prison
for murders he didn't commit and
although he won a multi-million dollar
settlement from his town in the state of
Illinois he wasn't pardoned
so as a society what can we do to combat
the perverse incentives of snitching we
at least need to understand how
information games are played in real
life history has morphed the Roman
goddess justicia into the modern image
of Lady Justice she's usually depicted
as holding a scale that balances the act
with its consequences she's blindfolded
which is meant to symbolize impartiality
but nearly 500 years ago Flemish painter
Peter rubell portrayed a static unmoving
Lady Justice wearing a blindfold to
suggest that she was failing to see
Injustice
so which is it is she impartial
or just
ignorant
I don't know
but I do know that as long as her lips
are free to play the oldest game in
crime and punishment snitching and
stitching
it might not even matter
and as always thanks for watching thanks
again to fishing Clash for sponsoring
vsauce2 download now
foreign
[Music]